This is the sanctuary, the cemetery of the witch where my soul is imprisoned after death
.
Is it okay to think that the forest of ruins I was
in just now is
a sanctuary?  Hey, I
guarantee that, but
is there
anything you want
to ask me?  But I've come to seek my tastes, clinging to my knowledge.
4.
This is the first time I've had a tea party like this,
so if I really want to change it, I'll ask for
a price at the end.  But it's not money,
what I want from you is pharmaceuticals.
That's the condition.
Even if you don't know it yet When
you know the place, you'll realize its value
What kind of feelings will you have for
me when that happens?
[music]
[applause]